jury deliberations just began in the
trial of three men charged with killing
a mod arbory in georgia last year travis
mcmichael his father gregory mcmichael
and their neighbor william roddy bryan
were all charged with murder and other
counts for the death of arbory aubrey is
a 25 year old black man who was jogging
in the neighborhood when he was shot to
death the state argues arbore was hunted
down in an act of racist violence the
defense is arguing that arbory was quote
lurking and posed an unpredictable
threat the case calls the idea of
self-defense itself into question so
let's bring in melissa redman a law
professor at the university of georgia
and former prosecutor to discuss the
details melissa welcome to quick take
give me the top line of what happened
today heading into these jury
deliberations what were the key
takeaways from closing arguments from
both sides
good afternoon madison thank you so much
for having me um this morning we saw the
state give their rebuttal closing
arguments essentially the state has the
ability or the the right to go first and
last in closing in criminal cases and
after hearing from their defense the
defense attorneys yesterday the state
concluded their closing arguments this
morning highlighting points um for
pointing to guilt of all three
defendants hitting on each point made by
the defense attorneys yesterday and
really kind of bringing home their
points in the case and that the
mcmichaels were not acting in
self-defense they did not effectuate a
lawful
citizen's arrest and giving all the
reasons why the jury should find in the
state's favor yeah the kind of topic of
citizens arrest is obviously a huge
integral part of this case can you walk
me through what the definition of that
is and remind me sort of how that topic
has played into the trial so far
sure the prior law in the state of
georgia was that a private person can
effectuate an arrest of a citizen for
crime or offense committed in their
presence or within their immediate
knowledge um that's the first paragraph
of that statute the second paragraph
states that if that offense is a felony
then the person has the right to um
prevent escape
of the offender um so what we have in
this case is the defense arguing that
they had knowledge or a reasonable cause
of suspicion basically probable cause to
believe that mr aubry had committed a
felony on a prior occasion and that they
were acting to prevent escape with that
felony on the day in question the
state's point is on the day in question
that mcmichael's had no knowledge
whatsoever of mr aubry committing
committing any offense let alone a
felony offense and that therefore they
had no right to try and effectuate a
citizen's arrest so the argument really
comes down to whether the jury believes
that the felony if one had been
committed had to have been in their
presence for immediate knowledge meaning
that day
or if they're entitled to take the
totality of the circumstances of their
all of their interactions with mr aubry
on prior occasions with a new from prior
videos that they saw on facebook page or
just neighborhood gossip whether they're
entitled to use that
for that reasonable and um
probable suspicion of a felony um that
he
they believe he was escaping from on the
day in question so for malice murder
they would have to show um
a
a malignant or abandoned abandoned and
malignant heart basically that they
acted with such depravity that it arises
to the level of
malice murder in georgia doesn't mean
what it may mean in other states there's
no premeditation required or anything of
that nature and of course the felony
murders mean that during the commission
of a felony um someone loses their life
and it was because of the commission of
that felony that caused the person to
lose their life in this case the
aggravated assaults being
um assaulting mr arbor with the trucks
from both the mcmichaels and mr bryan
and um with the weapon as well travis
mcmichael with the shotgun assaulting mr
aubry and those actions caused
the series of
events that led to mr auburn's death
so i know that you are a former
prosecutor melissa what grade would you
give the prosecution in this case how do
you think that they did and how do you
think that'll impact the outcome that we
hear in this trial
um i believe the prosecutor put on an
excellent case they were they they
provided the aubry family with excellent
advocacy um they dotted every eye across
every t and i'm familiar with uh miss
donatkowski and i expected nothing less
from her um they showed passion they
they showed um restraint in that of as
emotional as this case is we want you to
base your verdict on the evidence and
the evidence shows that the defendants
are guilty
i think she did a great job of rebutting
each of the defendants arguments and
kind of walking the jury through
the case step by step through each of
the charges telling the jury how they
should go about in their deliberation in
consideration of each of the charges
even um going to the extent of
explaining to them how they should fill
out the verdict form
um so
i believe that as excellent um
uh as a representation as the defendants
um provided their clients i believe mr
apostle did an amazing job with this
case yeah i quickly want to get your
thoughts too on the defense's arguments
looking yesterday at their closing
arguments um some some statements that
i'm not going to bother repeating but
ahmad's mother ended up exiting the
courtroom during these statements
how do you think something like that
lands with the jury did the defense do
that because of you know potentially the
racial makeup of the jury or what do you
see the strategy behind those comments
being and how do you think they'll sit
with the jury
i believe the strategy behind the com
comments was to show that there's been a
narrative of mr arbury being a runner
and driving through the neighborhood and
that's what he was doing on this
occasion the defense needs the jury to
believe that mr albert was in the
neighborhood for
unlawful purposes that he was there
breaking into houses or casing a
property or something to that nature not
that he was just out for a job so the
purpose behind the comment i believe was
to paint a picture of someone in khaki
pants with you know shoes with no shock
socks um was not out for a daily job
i think there would have been there was
a better way to say that a less
inflammatory way up and do um grading
way of saying that
um
i don't believe it was a off-the-cuff
comment of looking at the defense's
argument i believe everything they said
was planned and very well thought out um
and as you said it may have been they
and and one thing about trial advocacy
is you have to know your audience or
believe you know your audience so
you know one has to wonder whether or
not um the attorneys believe that that
type of comment would have landed well
with that particular jury
and we won't know until they return to
birth yeah in our final minute together
melissa uh do you have any insight or
intel into what you think the jury may
be most considering in these
deliberations and where you potentially
see these deliberations landing
i believe a lot of there may be a
question and i think they will focus a
lot on the citizens of our statute and
that is because both sides argued it
very differently the defense argued that
the
felony that mr arbory could have been
fleeing from did not have to occur or
that mcmichaels didn't have to know he
had committed a felony that day they
could have used all their knowledge
and their belief that he had committed a
prior offense of burglary
that he was fleeing from on the day to
effectuate a citizen's arrest the state
argued that the statute means that the
felony has to occur either in your
presence or immediately prior to your uh
immediately prior that you're attempting
to prevent the offender from escaping um
so it has to be very contemporaneous and
i think the charge um it doesn't do a
great job of clarifying that for the
jury
so they're left to kind of have to
figuring that figure that out themselves
and i think that's probably
what they will spend a lot of time
debating well we will certainly update
our audience with the verdict as it
comes in but melissa really appreciate
you giving us all the context on that
thank you so much